simplify everything maker the spokesman
in the guardian of a corrupt and
incompetent status quo and elite and you
make Trump the agent changed that
President Obama wasn't when Errol Morris
debuted his documentary about Steve ban
and last year at the Venice Film
Festival early reviewers charged that by
profiling the president's former chief
strategist and former executive chairman
of Breitbart calm the Academy
award-winning filmmaker was serving as a
mouthpiece for Donald Trump it was the
first time in decades that the acclaimed
director of the thin blue line and the
fog of war couldn't get a movie into
theaters the experience was so damn
weird people became so angry with me and
with the movie they certainly wanted to
deep platform not just Bannon but they
wanted to deep platform me and American
Dharma but now Morris's film is finally
coming to the big screen i sat down with
the 71 year old Morris whom Roger Ebert
called as great a filmmaker as Hitchcock
or Fellini to talk about the censorious
first reactions to his new film his
history with Elizabeth Holmes and
Thoreau knows and what he learned and
didn't learn about Steve bannon's
philosophy
Errol Morris thanks for talking to
reason thank you very much let's start
with the title
American Dharma Steve Bannon in your
discussions with him comes back to this
idea of Dharma as central to his
worldview it's hard for me to talk about
Baden's philosophy because Baden's
philosophy is a hodgepodge of
Catholicism Hindu philosophy pop
psychology it's almost like a vomit pad
of various unsorted undifferentiated
ideas I've made a career it seems to be
a career I can't really be sure even at
this point of chronicling various kinds
of self-deception people who imagine
themselves one way but in fact they
could be wrong in fact they are wrong
and dannan is my best effort that's what
puzzles me so much maybe they shouldn't
be puzzled maybe I am the one self
deceived here about what I'm doing but
here I have a guy and sees himself in
Napoleonic terms he imagines himself is
this world historical individual who's
changing the political landscape and
ushering in a new age for the working
class working class unite under the
banner of trumpism panin ISM but
underneath all of it is nonsense talk
and to me as often as not it comes very
close to what's the technical term
[ __ ] now he does at a certain point
in the
in the movie he he lays out his three
big things that he says her I guess
Bannon is amor trumpism stopping a mass
illegal immigration bringing
manufacturing jobs back from Asia and
ending pointless Foreign Wars is that
his program or is that you know or or
Bannon ISM is that plus a million
different things or is that its program
I suppose you could say that's his
program does the program really make any
sense so you want to protect
manufacturing jobs for the American
working class do I think that's a bad
thing no I think that's a good thing but
do I think the right way to do it is to
build a wall no I think it's [ __ ] Asst
I think that it's intellectually
dishonest I don't think it helps anybody
or anything it's violent it's
mean-spirited it's angry so is the
interest in talking to somebody like
Bannon is to get into the mindset yeah
one of the architects of this yes the
politics of anger yes well that might
lead us into a discussion of the early
reception of the of the documentary when
it was savaged yes I was gonna say when
it debuted but when it was savaged a
year ago roughly speaking you know and
I'm thinking there was a New Yorker
review that would the headline was
something like you know or that the
charge was that you let Bannen off the
hook and then there came a kind of
moment both where Bannon himself was
kind of cancelled from the culture he
was going to speak at The New Yorker
festival in New York with David Remnick
can have an interview and that you know
that was stopped your movie was
effectively kind of held hostage in all
of this it didn't get the distribution
that would have gotten one assumes if it
had been you had been talking to some
differently or if it was seen as no you
made him wriggle on the hook if I'm
talking to mr. Rogers I would have
didn't say so what let's talk about that
first off what's it feel like when you
produce something and it's you know you
think it's a well-wrought urn this is a
interesting in-depth revelatory
discussion with a person who is was in a
position of power and you're revealing
his inner working and then somebody says
well you just you know you just gave him
a platform what do you do if you were me
you think about killing yourself I
didn't do it
call me a coward I you're no Steve Banat
I know Steve Anna I know Steve Madden
and you're know Steve had him you feel
if you're me should I have made this
film what was I thinking or people write
about what they're saying I'm
susceptible to criticism if people tell
me I'm no damn good I'm certainly
willing to entertain that possibility
but the experience was so damn weird
people became so angry with me and with
the movie they certainly wanted to deep
platform not just Bannon but they wanted
to deep platform me and American Dharma
I would read reviews saying that this
movie was so toxic that was a word that
it would appear again and again and
again so poisonous did that it should
never have been made that it shouldn't
receive distribution and in one review
someone said that a head discredited
everything I had ever done it had lifted
the curtain on my lack
of moral scope moral fiber does one
enjoy reading that kind of thing and not
so much do you worry that's broadly
reflective you were talking earlier
about anger in American culture and
particularly politics it almost you know
this is you know coming from the liberal
side of things or the progressive side
of things with people saying you you
shouldn't be talking to somebody like
banning because to do so is to somehow
betray your you know what is right or we
shouldn't be engaging in conversation
with people we disagree with you do you
worry that that's a place that we're
getting to as a society a place we're
getting to we're there how do I even
explain it if I can explain it the
people so deeply freaked out by what
happened in 2016 that they just wanted
to go away they want to make believe it
never happened if it did happen it was
the victim we were the victims of a
terrible conspiracy people want to
disassociate themselves from it from the
horror of it mommy mommy please make it
go away I don't like this I don't think
I understood how strong that feeling a
feeling of just out-and-out despair and
fear I still feel it acutely two plus
years after the election do you feel
like the movie now with a little bit of
time and and the fact that ban and you
know is now a couple years out of or a
year and a half whatever no longer part
of the Trump administration he's less
potent to figure so that people can kind
of a pre approach
the movie without kind of just going
seeing right all the time without going
batshit crazy
yeah well Bannon is back in the picture
again he is organizing a radio show
podcast to help Trump in this period of
possible impeachment he's not gone away
deep platforming I don't know what
people's imagine it is maybe they see it
as a kind of magic Slade you pull up the
acetate window and bye-bye the image is
gone oh okay now he's still here and
he's still doing the same frightening
disruptive malicious things that he's
been doing all along do you think he was
actually instrument because there's in
in watching the movie there's kind of a
sense that he's obviously a [ __ ]
artist on some point like he's taking
credit yeah he's taking deferred credit
for certain things etc was he
responsible for Trump's victory do you
think or is he kind of like just he's a
very good salesman and he knows how to
take credit for a sale I was gonna take
place anyway I don't think it was a sale
it was gonna take place anyway I don't
like his politics I don't like his
crackpot ideologies but I do buy into
his belief that he made a big difference
in the election I wish it weren't so but
he from early on had decided to go after
Hillary Clinton the book Schweitzer's
Clinton cash it's not well known but
Schweitzer was writing previously about
hunter Biden and Joe Biden in the
Ukraine this is all a playbook for
better for worse I don't want to suggest
some
of arcane conspiracy but people were
after these people and they were
successful I mean if the aim was to
bring Hillary Clinton down by hook or by
crook they succeeded
does it matter if it's by hook or by
crook and to be honest I'm not exactly
sure which is hook in which is crook but
normally yeah you know Hillary Clinton
the by D's to a certain degree and Trump
certainly you know they reveal how power
operates or how how power circulates at
a very high level and to many people
when that's revealed it's like this
there's something wrong here there's
something skeevy here and it's not it
may not be the worst thing in the world
to understand how influential people you
know work and arrange things to their
benefit and then also to make it look as
if they did it all on their own that
it's all meritocratic or that it just
happened that's not a bad thing is it to
reveal how power operates probably not
and you feel that someone in the last
two or three years has lifted up a rock
and you see all of these bugs Democratic
and Republican bugs crawling and around
underneath the rock it makes me wonder
whether this whole idea that I've had of
America is just a delusion and that's an
America which is certainly not you know
it's not one without its many dark
corners or dark yeah like almost only
dark corners but it's a happier play
it's a fairer place than what you're
revealing now it says I used to talk
about fig-leaf equality that no one
really believes in equality but they do
believe in paying lip service to
equality fig-leaf equality the
appearance of equality tilting
Ward's rather than against equality
nowadays I feel that everything that to
me made America America not because it
was perfect equality perfect freedom
perfect fairness perfect justice but
somehow those as ideals have been
utterly abandoned and replaced with a
kind of cynicism and even beyond
cynicism a kind of Neel ism you know on
the left no fooling I only trouble with
the left is the left usually isn't left
enough for me I don't know what one is
supposed to do about what's going on I'm
a filmmaker so I try to make a film
about it I try to think about it in my
own small way you've taken heat for
doing commercials for theranos the the
great fraudulent well that's absurd well
let's talk about that and yeah what why
why are people wrong to be like you know
god dammit errol morris you think here
you're talking to Steve ban and you're
doing ads for Elizabeth Holmes why why
do i why should i watch anything you do
maybe you shouldn't I earn my living
predominantly through commercials I've
done commercials for now well over 20
years
a lot of my income comes from directing
commercials not from making my own
movies I've turned down commercials most
recently I turned down a whole set of
commercials for jewel now they smoked it
vaping the vaping company once their
help they're saving hundreds of
thousands of lives well so the claim was
I had my doubts I didn't want to get
involved
I turned down military advertising I've
been offered various campaigns over the
years just don't want to take them I
don't feel I should be encouraging poor
kids to get their faces blown off in
Afghanistan and Iraq so I don't do it
I've turned down a lot of commercials
over the years maybe not as many as I
should but a lot so besides the the
paycheck not a small thing
wait a second with Theron oh yes so with
theranos the company that represented me
for commercials told me about Elizabeth
Holmes now this is before the [ __ ] hit
the fan Elizabeth Holmes was on the
cover of endless business magazines
she was endlessly written about she was
the 30 year old multi billionaire who
presided over this company Farrah knows
every time I'm offered okay I've done
endless work I could go through a list
of companies but there's an awful lot of
them IBM Apple Best Buy Citibank and on
and on and on and on
do I do due diligence for every company
that I work for I don't for the most
part I know something about the
company's going into it just like I knew
something about jewel when I decided not
to take that job very nose I liked
personally like Elizabeth Holmes and I
saw what she was doing as being possibly
good I'm scared of needles I don't like
having my blood taken I thought just be
a great thing doing an analysis on the
basis of one or two drops of blood taken
with a finger stick I liked it
without knowing really whether it was
workable technology so I take the blame
for that although there was no
indication at that time that this was
going to fall down like a house of cards
would you would you be interested would
she be the type of person you would love
to do a documentary about or the type of
figure you would find interesting when
you talk about people who are you know
kind of self self delusional I love
pariahs I'm not revealing anything even
surprising would I make a documentary
about Elizabeth Holmes I wanted to even
after I knew that she was in trouble I
wanted to but it was not going to be a
puff piece it was not going to be
advertising advertising you're being
paid to promote a company and I feel and
I still feel that there's a mystery at
the heart of Elizabeth Holmes that has
gone on examined
what did she think she was doing was she
some confidence woman a trickster who
never really believed in her own
technology that she had the capacity to
deceive herself to delude herself what
was actually going on in all of this you
started out by talking about many people
who responded negatively and hostile to
American Dharma to the to the Steve
Bannon documentary and your engagement
with him were they just didn't want to
deal with something horrible that had
happened they wanted to go away and one
way to do that is to ignore it or
pretend that it never happened that is
one way to do it yes so what what do you
hope then now that the movie is getting
the release you know that it arguably
deserved a year ago
what what is the thing that you want
audiences to take away from it more than
anything else right people I want people
to see the movie and to think about it
to think about the issues that are
expressed in the movie to think about
what's happening in this country perhaps
why it's happening and to think really
seriously about what to do about it
what to do about it is not avoiding it
what to do about it is not pretending
that nothing is really happening or that
it was an accident or it was some
implacable conspiracy imposed on us by
the Russians or whoever I think we need
to actually confront what's going on in
this country and try to work as hard as
we possibly can to changing things
you
[Music]